dis moi quel clip tu portes et je te
dirai qui tu es
bref il ya une économie politique de là
que c'est que orgue secrète leurs
propres dirigeants leur comité social de
que leurs dirigeants naturel île secrète
leur propre droit
on y lit à l'égalité de tous devant la
queue mais lorsque il y à une femme
enceinte elle n'a pas une priorité
absolue mais elle dispose d'une vitesse
de progression améliorée dans là que
nous avons surtout des femmes entre 20
et 60 ans qui achètent pour leur patron
leur mari ou leur hantise m
et c'est pour une plaisanterie dans la
plupart des cas vous ne pouvez pas
rentrer ici sans sourire parce que tout
est à la fois mignon et stupide
lorsque l'on a nagé une fois nul on a
vraiment plus envie de remettre un
vêtement cela permettrait un truc ne
connaît pas ils connaissent pas la crise
de mieux le connaître justement pas
demander la lune
il ne faut pas demander la lune et c'est
la ouate de phoques
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non non loris et you are great il dit
vous êtes très joli non non non non non
c'était non non il a dit ça mais ça lui
arrive d antan rien je peux pas vous
traduire ce qu'il a dit il a dit
j'aimerais bien vous aurez pleure pas du
tout j'ai dit jean rey lui répéter avec
van damme ont fait l écran qu lingerie
on recule l'âge
oui il des mouches exclusivement on m'a
dit alain storck c'est peut-être le
modèle anglais et vous voyez combien
derrière la sophistication du modèle les
anglais sont en réalité plus rythme pour
marquer sur ce slip devant et derrière
une main de femme avec allianz ici bien
des proches qui vous parle en direct de
monaco se déroule actuellement le 225e
festival annuel du film pornographique
sous le haut patronage s'il n'y a pas de
patronne à centro porno le film que j'ai
vu pour vous hier soir au familial ciné
de monaco s'appelle oh oui oh là là
c'est bon encore oh la la
étonnant nous tout d'abord une fois de
plus de l'indigence des traducteurs qui
baptise oh oui oh là là c'est bon encore
oh là là une oeuvre dont le titre
original est on y est cela la x-bow de
once again
oh là là mais ne faisons pas la fine
bouche à ce détail près oh oui oh là là
c'est bon ou encore oh là là est une
oeuvre attachante à bien des égards
danser
non oui bien des égards
toutes les portes sont fermées mais
suite à mon avocat